hi there today we're looking at faster
neural network training with data
echoing by dummy choy Alexandre Paso
Christopher J shall you and George e
doll so on a high level this paper
basically says you should repeat data
that's already in memory in order to
speed up the entire process of neural
network training and it also says that
this can speed up your wall time without
hurting your performance too much and I
have mixed feelings about it so let's
jump in so they basically make a point
of saying that machine learning doesn't
happen in just one thing it's not like
SK learn not fit anymore it is more of a
pipeline so what do we mean by this if
you have if you think of something like
you want to train an image net model
what you want to do is you have like
your data set somewhere and that could
be on in a database it could be in the
network somewhere so if you have even
something larger than image net you
probably store it on a central server
and an Amazon bucket somewhere so this
is in AWS and the first thing you
actually need to do is you need to read
that data set now usually you're not
gonna have enough memory on a machine to
just load in the entire dataset into
memory so that means this process here
is streaming so this is continuously
streaming data points and once you have
used the data point you're going to
throw it away because you need space for
the next one right and so the streaming
is content continuously the next process
is read and decode that means you have
to you know read it from the network and
actually bring it into a format where
you can use it usually something like a
numpy array or a tensor flow tensor you
need to apply some shuffling because
usually the order you can't really trust
the order that it is stored in it
oftentimes there is like a bias in the
ordering so you need some sort of a
shuffle buffer here um then often you
want to apply some date augmentation to
it
means that you have one image and we
know for these models if this is your
cat we know for these models that what
can help is to basically make many many
different images from one image so this
could be by cropping part of it and
saying well if it was a cat before the
small upper right part here is still a
cat so this is one update it's called
data element ation and you're gonna
apply a whole bunch of these things so
you can crop you can rotate the image a
bit it's still a cat right and you can
also change its luminance and a bit of
its colors you can jitter the colors you
can horizontally flip it and it'll still
be a cat and that's basically how you
make many data points from one data
point and we know that helps then what
you want to do is you want to batch this
data so you want to put it into mini
batches
since you've shuffled here that means
when the next time the same data point
comes along it's going to be matched
with a different with a different group
of images and of course augmented
differently with a different group of
images and that basically means it's a
different training batch for the model
so this entire pipeline is basically a
way that we take data points that we
have and we make a whole bunch of
variations and various groupings and
batches of it and we know that helps
enormously with the generalization
capability of your final models and then
here you do your apply your SGD update
so that's usually where you forward
propagate your data through your network
which here is f it'll get like some y
hat as an output and then you have your
labels that also come through the
pipeline and you have some sort of loss
function L that takes both as an input
and gives you an output and then you do
your back propagation so the back
propagation would go through your loss
function through your network and update
the network parameters such that your
network learned something right now this
step to the right here is
usually what we focus on when we do deep
learning the step on the right here all
of this this can be done on a GPU or is
usually done on something like a GPU or
a TPU right but in these things are
getting faster and faster the point the
paper makes is that DTP use and GPUs of
the world are getting faster but this
entire other thing right here this is
basically CPU land now I know there is
some data augmentation now happening on
the GPU and so on but in in essence you
can think of a pipeline where the thing
to the left is happening on CPU and the
thing to the right is happening on TPU
and even even worse let's say the speed
is continuously is continuously
increasing so in your pipeline the kind
of speed would be so here is the network
reading and here over here is the GPU
SGD step and this is speed basically the
further to the right in your pipeline
you go the faster your the faster your
hardware gets and that means that if
this since this is a continuous pipeline
right that basically means that if I
input something here it goes through the
pipeline and even if this is all running
in parallel that this thing over here is
going to idle this since this is the
fastest part of the pipeline it is going
to just idle a lot right it because
because it can only consume things as
fast as this thing can produce now if
you if you have some sort of a multi GPU
machine and just train imagenet like you
just around the code usually you're this
is not the bottleneck usually your GPUs
here are at hundred 100 percent capacity
so this paper is not for you but if you
are let's say a big company have these
networks
which have a big data set have very
expensive data augmentation this happens
for example this can happen in NLP and
so on this can be quite your situation
where the earlier in the pipeline the
slower it is and don't you just love
these graphics so here's here's time and
apparently it goes in both directions
and so does it go like this I think what
they mean is just time goes in this
direction and you're here and you're
upstream so you're upstream is your
network this is your network reading or
your pre-processing and the downstream
this is the GPU so as you are
pre-processing things you you and this
should be this should be different it
should me okay
to correct this right here this is idle
and this is running so as your upstream
processes images right at the beginning
your GPU is idle but then as soon as it
ships off the first batch of images your
GPU can run now it's running while
you're doing that your upstream your
network is still reading new images
pre-processing them and so on but it
cannot is too slow to insert a batch at
the time that the GPU is done the time
the GPU is done it's still processing
this batch so the GPU is idle until here
where it finally manages to process that
batch and then the GPU is running again
I think that would have been a much
better graphic but you know so their
goal basically is that what you have is
right here for example after the batch
what you'll do is you scrap this
connection you take this and you put it
into a smaller buffer and the buffer is
is a repeat buffer so what it does is it
simply will repeat
the whatever you have in the buffer
until something new comes in right so
new data point comes in you just output
that data point again again again again
the for the GPU it's gonna feel like
these are all new batches and they will
continuously come in but it's always the
same until the next data point comes in
and then you output that one again and
again and again and again now the the
actual factor here you can of course
tune by hand or you can just say repeat
until something else comes in in this
paper they have an explicit factor where
they say we repeat each data point four
times or three times or so on so this is
data echoing you basically echoed the
data point multiple times and this can
be done in various places so they
experiment with echoing in any of these
places right here so the egg they
experiment with it right here after
reading and decoding after shuffling no
I think always before shuffling because
if you if you have a shuffle buffer
anyway they say it makes sense that if
you do the echoing you you do your
shuffle buffer after you're echoing so
here
then after augmentation and after
batching so the experiment with these
three locations in in echoing now what
could be the downturn of something like
this the downturn of course is that this
SGD procedure right here basically it
relies on the data incoming being an iid
sample from your data distribution right
that's that's how we formulate SGD is
that there's always new data incoming
now if you just output the same data
point all the time that could that is
like no new information first of all and
second of all it could buy us the SGD
update such that you it because it sees
the same date it doesn't it sees the
same information over and over its gonna
think that's the whole dataset right so
potentially it can make too many steps
in
the wrong direction that just happens to
be it the bias in this particular data
point right so the iid assumption is is
is invalid now why do you experiment
with this in different locations because
what you expect is that it hurts more it
or it hurts less the earlier you
introduced this so if you introduced
echoing right here so if you echo your
data until new data from the network
comes in it's still going to be shuffled
differently right it's and it's still
going to be augmented differently so
each time the data point comes out of
the echo buffer it is going to be
shuffled and it is going to be augmented
in a different way than the last time
the same data point came out and this is
going to be batched together because
you've shuffled differently it's going
to be batched together with a different
bunch of data points and that means SGD
gets new information but if you go on to
the very last thing where you just after
the batch right here or you input the
echo that means SGD it just gets to see
the same batch of data augmented in the
same way all the time right so the of
course where you exactly have to echo
you have to trade this off so you have
to trade off the how much you basically
violate the iid fresh data assumption
against where in your data pipeline is
the bottleneck so if your bottleneck is
in the data augmentation it made me make
little sense to echo before that because
your bottleneck is the data augmentation
and that being said if the bottleneck is
that you don't have enough GPUs then it
probably doesn't make sense to data echo
at all though their experiments are
somehow wonky on this but so let's dive
in they make the following claims let's
just go through them really quick data
again reduces the amount of upstream
that it's very think of network reading
or augmentation computation needed to
reach a competitive out-of-sample
error rate on various date sets and
model architectures second data echoing
can provide a wall time speed-up in
practice third data echoing can support
a wide range of echoing factors and
that's the echoing factor is how often
you repeat the data fourth the
effectiveness of data echoing depends on
the intersection point in the training
pipeline sorry in the insertion point
that's what that's what our hypothesis
was right
fifth data echoing can benefit from
additional shuffling after echoing but
does not require it and six countering
expectations data echoing reaches the
same final error rate as well tuned
baselines so I am can absolutely except
one through five especially in like an
actual practical in the wild setting but
six we will see about six so let's jump
into their their models they sorry about
that
they train the following four models so
they train a transformer on these two
data sets LM one D and common crop so
packets technically it's five models on
language modeling they train the ResNet
thirty-two on C for ten they train the
resonate 50 on imagenet and they train
SSD on cocoa now here is the accuracies
they get and here is sorry this is the
target so what they do is they train
these models and then they say okay
what's the accuracy we reach and then
they set a target value so on on
resonate 50 on imagenet a very common
number to reach is something like
seventy six point five if you look at
for example torch vision models they
reach something like like this
and so they say well our target accuracy
here is just a little bit below that so
and then we just measure how many steps
or how many they're measurement here is
data points so how many actual fresh
training samples do we need to reach
this target and this is this is where it
gets wonky because for example take the
91% here on c4 10 that is quite quite
low and also the resonate 50 is I mean
this is standard but still image net is
much further nowadays and I think the
effectiveness of something like this has
a lot to do with how competitive you
want to get maybe this is all just an
effect of how much on under par your
this target performance really is and I
I would I would expect that even though
they say it doesn't hurt their
performance in their experiments I would
at least expect it will hurt your
performance in general if you try to get
competitive because these things aren't
as as as of now at least the ones I know
like the the resonates aren't really
competitive but so what do they do the
they measure data eken with an echoing
factor of two so that means data that's
incoming is output twice in a row any
every data point that's coming in is
just emitted twice from the buffer and
then the next data point is emitted
twice and so on and what they measure
again is the fresh examples red so how
many fresh data points do you need to
achieve something this is a good
measurement because this is kind of
independent of hardware so if you're if
you are really in the situation where
your GPU is twice as fast as the as your
the rest of your pipeline then an
echoing factor of two will speed up at
most your training procedure by a factor
of two all right so you have the
baseline in red and then you have a
batch echoing which is where you echo
what we said at the worst possible time
right after batching so this might hurt
your performance the most but also it
has a potential to be the fastest if
you're if maybe your augmentation is
very expensive then sorry or your
batching you have example echoing after
augmentation so that would mean you use
the augmentation is very expensive so
you save the Augmented data point and
then you omit it multiple times but each
time it is batch differently so it is it
is shuffled and then badged with
different other data points so you have
a shuffle buffer after it and then you
have example account before date
augmentation so that means the same data
point emitted multiple times will be
augmented in different ways and
basically will lead to slightly
different data points so the results
here are pretty much what you could
expect in that the earlier you do the
echoing as you can see here the more
this echoing helps so the number if you
for example this is the object
segmentation task the baseline needs
this many fresh examples to reach this
target accuracy with batch echoing not
only do you sort sorry with batch
echoing you need less fresh training
examples so that means even though you
kind of terrain on the same data twice
you you this helps you more or this
helps you it doesn't help you fully
because the dashed line here is the if
if it would help you as much as a fresh
data point you'd be at the dashed line
right this is exactly half of this
because the echoing factor is two so if
you're if a repeated data point was as
useful as a fresh data point you'd be at
the dashed line as you can see right
here you're not at the dashed line but
at least it doesn't hurt
you might expect that it hurts but it
doesn't hurt it actually speeds up so
the repeated data points at least have
some utility again this is only useful
if you're here
if you have this asymmetry in your
pipeline if your pipeline is actually
symmetric and you do an echoing factor
of two the wall time here the wall time
plot would look this for the baseline
and then almost twice as high for the
batch echoing because even though it
needs the same amount of fresh or almost
the same amount of fresh example it you
echo it each one twice so it needs to
process it twice so you little take much
longer so again this is useful if you
have this asymmetry and if the echoing
factor is kind of smaller than your
asymmetry otherwise you're simply
wasting time repeating data points then
if you do example echoing here after
augmentation you use even less fresh
data points and if you do it before
augmentation this is really surprising
you almost get the benefit of fresh data
points which is something you might
expect right because an Augmented newly
shuffled data point is kind of almost a
new data point but still it's quite
surprising that you almost get to the
level of the of the theoretical possible
and also here on the image net task now
here is actually an example where you
can see that it hurts to do this batch
echoing because the reasons why could
hurt is just that you have you violate
this iid assumption you basically have
correlated data points this is a big big
problem for example in reinforcement
learning where already by nature of you
running episodes and then feeding the
episodes back into the training
procedure you have correlated data
points and that hurts your performance
here actually compared to the to the
baseline but then if you go to example
echoing and the example I claim before
augmentation again you get a speed-up
which is pretty cool
okay so they do a bunch of other
experiments and I appreciate these
experiments here to really show what's
going on and until when can you push
this so here they have a plot of example
echoing before augmentation can reduce
training time for ResNet 50 on imagenet
so this is before augmentation and the
echoing factor describes how often you
repeat each data point so this goes from
two to five and you can see that
basically you you get the speed-up you
have you just sort of get it for free as
you can see the dashed line again is as
if if at repeated data point were as
useful as a fresh data point you'd be at
the dashed line and you can see right
here that you are just above this dashed
line so this can help a lot and so this
is the fresh examples red and this is
the wall time in their particular
situation in that case it doesn't help
as much but again it if that very much
depends on how the asymmetry in your
pipeline is now in these experiments I
would actually appreciate something like
they do down here where I would always
like to see where it breaks so how far
can you go with the echoing factor until
it doesn't help anymore because this
sort of tells me pretty much nothing I
want to see where is the low point where
is kind of the optimal echoing factor
and what can you tell me about this
optimal echoing factor how can we you
determine it sort of beforehand or how
can you reason how does it connect to
the different parts of your architecture
so if I have to point out a flaw in this
paper it would be that right here I
would expect the them to continue this
echoing factor increase until it breaks
sort of like they do down here
this is for I believe this is for the
transformer on lm1 B now here they have
a batch
of 1024 and you can see and this is the
this is their standard setting for the
transformer the 1,024 batch size you can
see that the base line uses this many
1.5 times ten to the seventh fresh
examples to Train until their target if
you increase the echoing factor by two
you basically need half as many fresh
examples as long as you echo each one
twice again very surprising the fact how
close you can get to the as if each
match were a perfect fresh data point
but you can see as you increase this
echoing factor and here is exactly what
I said right you at some point this
Hertz at some point you get to the point
where the non iid nests the correlation
of the date of successive data points
will actually hurt you and they make a
point here of saying that this is for
example dependent on batch size now in
this experiment over here they have a
larger batch size and here is again the
the baseline number of data points to
reach the target and you can see again
it goes down but now with the echoing
factor where before you had a you and an
increase again now it continues to
decrease again and will be interesting
to see where it goes up here and how the
number at the lowest like here the four
and here the I don't know what is gonna
be maybe the 16 how this will kind of
depend on your batch size and here is
another problem and that's what I
alluded to at the beginning this this
performance dependence now I have not
read anything differently in the paper
so I had to assume that they trained
this here this number of fresh examples
to reach the target is still the target
that they determined at the beginning so
it's that three point nine
in the table that three-point-nine was
achieved with this batch size with a
thousand and twenty four and we know
especially in language models that
larger batch sizes will lead to a better
performance even if you need say more
sample so here you can see that the
samples here is 1.5 and here it's
actually four because you increase that
batch size so that will tell you
something
1.5 and 4 that is that is like a times
okay that's like n times two point five
so you go with the batch size of x four
and you need to point five more more
fresh training samples to reach the same
target accuracy first of all we know
that the larger batch sizes can reach
higher target accuracies so again these
these results the dependence of them on
the actual performance to the maximum
achievable value to me that's kind of a
shady world here - always - always say
okay how long does it take to reach that
particular target because we know that
this model right here can reach a much
higher target but we don't know this
about these models here what is their
kind of performance in the limit and
they try to make these experiments but I
don't really believe them maybe yeah and
yes and the second direct that will that
would be type that is already
interesting so this ratio right here
this 2.5 to 4 this ratio must mean
something right it's it's I'd go to a
higher batch size four times higher
batch size and I need 2.5 many more
fresh training samples to reach the same
target that must somehow tell you
something about the usefulness of a
single data point versus a succession of
data points right so it doesn't seem
because I would expect if each data
point was valuable I would expect this
to be times four and if it were if it
were times one
so if it were no no speed-up at all
sorry not times for if it would be times
1 it would mean I need the same number
of fresh training samples right no
matter how I batch them but it were
times 4 that means basically that it
doesn't matter really how many training
points I have in a batch as long as I
have enough and the 2024 seems to be
enough it just it just matters how many
you know SGD steps I do so basically
what we're saying SGD isn't getting the
most out of these data points and this
ratio this 2.5 mm this this tells you
something about the information content
of a of an additional data point versus
the usefulness content of an additional
step of SGD and I would expect that to
depend to intrinsically be connected to
the where the low point of this echoing
factor is because that's exactly what
the echoing does it trades off freshness
of data point versus doing more steps on
the on on the same information and for a
paper especially paper by Google brain I
this this is a connection that I would
love to see investigated but enough of
the ranting they do investigate other
things they do investigate for example
what happens if we just up the batch
size and you can see here yeah this is
interesting even the baseline needs more
fresh samples as you up the batch size
but and at the beginning this batch
echoing for example doesn't help doesn't
hurt but doesn't help but as you go to
higher and higher batch sizes this batch
echoing starts to help more and more
again I believe this is connected to the
usefulness of the single data point at
some point your batch sizes just too
large for the problem you'd rather do
more steps and that's why this helps but
also this model right here might have a
higher ceiling accuracy so and it is the
question whether this model right
has the same or whether this model right
here the batch echoing model would
actually fall back to the ceiling
accuracy of one of these models over
here yeah in any case their point is
basically that as you increase the batch
size this echoing tends to help more
relatively because maybe it's because
what I said right they say as batch size
increases the performance of patch
checking a relative to the baseline
stays either stays the same or improves
while for example echoing it either
stays the same or it gets sorry well for
example echoing it either stays the same
or gets worse dashed lines indicate the
expected values if repeated examples
were as useful as fresh examples yeah so
there is an intrinsic connection here
between the usefulness of more data and
usefulness of doing additional steps and
here the example echoing you can almost
see it as more data because especially
here you're gonna do augmentation on top
of it and you see the non augmented
versus the Augmented ratio changes
dramatically from here to here okay
final set of experiments as you can tell
this is more mostly an experimental
paper and it is always easy to criticize
experimental papers and rightfully so
because I would not trust this very much
but given that it comes from a big
institution and it is a very very well
written paper I would trust it more than
I would a regular paper and I would say
if you're in practice this is certainly
worth trying
absolutely I'm just I just think that
some of the things aren't aren't
researched like some of my questions
aren't answered of this so they
investigate sizes so they now build
shuffle buffers so we have batch echoing
but they say ah but we can do batch
echoing with shuffle
buffers so after the batch echoing right
we have this state where we have the
batching and then we have the echoing so
this is our echo buffer where we output
the each data point multiple times and
then we have another buffer which is a
shuffle buffer now the shuffle buffer
just collects data points and then
shuffles them around before outputting
them and that means even though we you
know output this five times it might not
come out five times after each other it
might be that it comes out once and then
another data point that was already in
the shuffle buffer comes out and then it
will just say that in total it comes out
five times but it is first shuffle
together with a bunch of other data
points of course this uses more memory
but of it returns to that more iid
setting and you can see here as the
buffer size increases then the
performance gets more and more to the
performance that you would have with
completely fresh data right so again
trading off freshness and freshness and
doing multiple steps with by by
basically repeating repeating data
points straight out versus repeating
data points shuffled and also here you
have the same with example echoing so if
you apply the shuffle buffer to example
echoing and you increase its size you
can get very very very close to the
performance that you would get with a
fresh data which of course if you
increase the shuffle buffer to the size
of the data set you are at the situation
that's the limit you are at the
situation of fresh data right if you do
example echoing it all right so here is
where it gets into the funky part where
they say we actually measure the
validation cross-entropy
and the validation accuracy versus the
number of fresh examples red and here I
wanna concentrate on the ResNet 50 on
imagenet and as you can see most of
these models
they pretty much end up in the same
place here it's just that the echoing
models end up there faster right and
this this is I mean this is where it
gets a bit confusing honestly because
why do you have this super sharp thing
here because usually and here it sort of
speeds up in the middle you see it you
see that and then it kind of sharply
declines is this may be because they
drop the learning rate or something now
my main thing is that the performance
here even though that this target thing
is lower than then the even though this
target thing is the same for everyone
it is lower than the best reachable
accuracy and I'm just this this is just
confusing if this is really true
well if this is really true I think we
have a lot to learn about SGD yet and
how we're not actually doing SGD
correctly and because it seems like
almost the the echo versions are better
or reach a better accuracy than the
baseline I don't know do they just cap
it at the performance I don't think so I
think they say they let it reach they
also have these things right here these
these curves where they say this is the
best we reach and this is the resonant
32 on C 410 again
91% on C 410 is just very very low and
I'm almost thinking that okay this might
help if you just throw something that we
know is kind of overpowered because we
can reach 99% or at least you can reach
something like 94% on C for 10 easily
easily with a network smaller than
ResNet 32 maybe this effect manifests if
you if you have actually something that
could reach higher but for some reason
you only reach this low
I'm not sure but this is confusing and
if this is really true yeah I would just
if it's true which I believe I believe
this paper it might be just an effect of
not reaching the actual ceiling and
again look at this this is just the
curves are just strange right you have
the echoing before augmentation or like
it seems like it's outperforming the the
fresh data points I don't know there's a
little bell in my head that doesn't like
this if it's actually true then you know
that's cool but yeah so my main
criticisms are a bit with the
experimental methodology for example
where they increase the batch size but
still reach the same target accuracy
even though we know that there is a
higher ceiling if you increase the batch
size for language models my other
criticism is the non investigation of
this connection this connection right
here maybe but all in all it's a pretty
cool paper if I had a big company with
these pipeline issues I would absolutely
implement this this seems like a
no-brainer to do this and can help you
tremendously all right that was it thank
you for listening if you're still here
subscribe like tell a friend bye bye